so the magic that happens is something
you can't find anywhere that because
everything's so overproduced I was
always surprised when I started working
on TV shows how produce they were like I
was like oh right that said that that
segment there I'll be funny on its own
we don't even have to worry about it and
they're like what do you mean every
single thing has to be written now so
much jobs online I used to work in
morning radio and you'd be really
surprised how much everything is
orchestrated morning radio even the call
ins are most of them are fake like most
of the call ins of people who are
calling in like for segments and
different stuff like that are paid
actors which is like do you know my mind
you have no friends who would do it for
ya right somebody yeah it's yeah so like
any of those like you know Ryan Seacrest
like War of the Roses and all that
that's all fake guys there anything
worse the morning radio now how good how
it's still around akom zones well five
here here we go we got Brent job in the
building
there's nothing worse for me when I have
to do press hey we got Britain's job
here in the buildings here so I'm kind
of dig Conor McGregor could be plug in
and I'm like yeah it's gonna sell em so
what about the days we can punch in the
face out but is that for you my favorite
thing is there's always a part where
they acknowledge that you have a podcast
but they don't really want to talk about
it and they don't want to face the fact
that like you know you have a following
from mod cast ago they're sitting there
like see I get a different thing I get
it I get there you so we're gonna jump
on this call wind it we're gonna do this
about 15 minutes and I just tried to
podcast you mind jumping on with me
we'll just do a quick hour I'm not doing
your podcast I break out my [ __ ]
podcast falling on you no I'm not doing
your podcast yeah yeah my favorite is
like when you're explaining to them like
yeah we do it every Monday it packs up
the main room of the Comedy Store it's a
live show and you just get to see these
sad morning radio DJs go further and
further into their shell like yeah
they're like well we'll be right back I
got lucky because I used to used to be
my dream when I was a little kid to be a
radio DJ I thought it was the coolest
possible gig I mean I was like a little
kid like you know
hi I was a little kid and I'm like
that's the coolest gig I was recording
songs off the radio on one cassette
player and then you'd switch the other
cassette you know what I mean and I
would host my own radio show and I was
obsessed with this one DJ back in
Youngstown I won't say his name so it's
not that's no fair but I was awesome I
was writing to make shadow he was on hot
101 he was and was a big afternoon DJ on
a pop station but I thought it was the
coolest thing at the time and then one
day they announced like hey go down to
phantom fireworks tomorrow and you'll
get - you'll get to meet ba ba ba ba you
know this DJ and I went and I met him
and it was one of the most disappointing
sad things that he was just gonna booth
all by himself just no one no one cared
no everybody was just walking right by
him to go into the fireworks store and I
went up and I was like hey man you're
one of my heroes nice to meet you and
he's like oh okay good sure yeah you
know tough gig man they're like four
sometimes 3:30 yeah who do I every
morning yeah if you look at just the
stats of people that work those shifts
they don't live as long as others it's a
rough gig man yeah you you looked up a
study recently that shows that we study
this study was just conducted the census
showed that DJ's die earlier than normal
people that do the studio production oh
I go straight for career change
something mad when I say the baby
because I don't want this guy's name
getting out I was doing something a
venue and Showtime was there to see me
do my set and the show was started at
9:00 9:45 and it's 10:45 I'm like I'm
the only comic in the back of like what
the [ __ ] and the lady run the joint goes
oh there's no one here we need to go out
there MC and just do an hour what she
was just do - I do - as long as you can
cuz we don't know where anyone else is I
want come on man I went that's show time
down there
come on help me out here she goes I
don't want to do and she Latinos are
there any other comics this guy goes I'm
a comic
here's what's your name and again I only
say his name and I go cooing us dude I
know you're a comic killing me doing
comic us I did kill Tony oh now I'm like
you just did the one mini us yeah and
then he's like but I've done more coming
anyone else here she goes so you'll go
out I should have you least I'd be an
easy gig he say the comedy and then goes
out there and ate all the dicks man
eating brendan jobs favorite comic he
chose me for this gig Tommy on kill Tony
you know I could eat dicks for 60
seconds but watch me for 10 minutes
enjoy this character that is a star on
this show called feminist Stacey she
represents you know all women and you
know just sort of like those types of
feminists that you see on social media
and stuff that just are intolerable and
you hate everything I ran one in Austin
because on it has a house there for like
the there their guests they bought a
house and I'm saying at this house and
there's a we there's a porch light on
and she comes out and in the yard
there's like signs like purple green
orange black white everyone's approved
in this house and then it's like vote
YES on amendment 7 all that [ __ ] she's
so earthy she's like a liberal and she
comes out and she's all hey are you
staying there like yeah I'm staying here
and I go but I don't own it because
nothing I know loans it she was I just
bought a new out and he's like to keep
my owl up like Jesus Christ no I've got
a new owl in the crib and just was like
[ __ ] on us yeah I thought everybody
was accepted here
but not lights Oh do you have an issue
with women Brendan Schaub I'm sorry my
feminist Stacy here are you talking
disparagingly about women and earthy
folk what else do you want to talk about
Brendan oh do I want to get below the
belt now I don't think so
what's the boys hey how come there isn't
a female that's in the running for batts
go ahead a year
Brendan huh oh you got your you got your
Theo von your deadly eyes you don't get
Tony but you get your wrap up [ __ ] on
there what about a full grown
independent smart one man man this is
feminist ACC bro who's upset about
everything everything I'm triggered by
everything on the show
no estrogen on the show right now except
in this couch right here testosterone is
off the charts yeah are you talking
about your so you have a lot of beard
hair coming in Stacy sorry I'm a full
grown woman and I let my body free you
should see my pits
I'm completely unshaven and guess what
yes my pubes are a mess Brendan because
guess what as a woman I can keep them if
I want it is my body my choice yes I
have nipple hair too but you will not
see them unless I want to because I
could free the nipple right now that is
my choice as a woman if I want to
protest it that's me the only thing
that's that this nice and womanly in
here is the way that Brendan is sitting
right it's nice to see your name'll tail
popping at the bottom of those jeans
it's beautiful let it free
and let everything go below the belt
that needs to be out there temple tale
like a fighter in the skin down there
[Music]
you're keeping him up he needs his rest
any idea don't buy a [ __ ] owl oh yeah
who does that who who does it huh man
are you making me sweat Stacy you are
out of control today yeah sorry I just
wanted to drop by fighter and the kid
you're lucky Brian's not here to be all
over you Stacy Oh take me to oh I'm sure
there would be a me too movement and I
would report his ass immediately yeah
he'd put it in your low-budget movie
okay you know what this is enough I
don't know how much more I can take it
that's feminist Stacy out you think of
the state of comedy today strong strong
over examined over examined yes what
does that mean I'm tired of them talking
about comedy and talking about us like
we're poets and [ __ ] yeah god I agree
with that
we're not Allen Ginsberg we're a bunch
of [ __ ] I [ __ ] agree we're a
bunch of clowns
learn to greet us enough about every
subject to make fun of it and then stop
reading I agree you read more than any
comic I know I do
most of us borderline full-blown [ __ ]
I've said this well that you're all
awesome you are a classic example of
very smart and all the great things but
but I'm it it's when we start taking
like I watched a little bit of I haven't
seen the show but I'm dying up here
god bless Andrew Santino and Eric
Griffin all my friends who are great
guys and I hope the show goes on forever
but the one thing I didn't watch it
because as a comic who's lived this life
yeah when they were talking about your
jobs to tell the truth
against all odds and and they're
creating this sort of like Perry yeah
all right no I know but say this well I
know every time when the you know we've
seen a lot of comics get in trouble and
of course justifiably so and whenever I
read a lot of the stuff they're like
this person was anointed as the is the
top guy I'm like not by us No
you don't have those conversations no
new york times NPR The Huffington Post
you dorks decided someone was the voice
of a generation and we're like what are
you talking about their farts whoo what
are you doing read a real book that's so
true why are you doing this Thomas job
is to shed light on the truth not at all
you make me laugh [ __ ] who
percent of the time yeah
to Chris Rock hold him accountable he's
the guy Chris Rock tells you no I said
but Chris Rock Chris Rock is right yeah
almost the whole day like but the rest
but not dead it's not it's still not the
deepest like you get a get a deeper
you're gonna get a deeper read on things
all things race if you read Tom asta
Coates and then Thomas Sol you where you
would never base your knowledge on a
single source you'd be it more on it
yeah yeah but you're pinning down these
people's like well they're the voice of
comedy what are you even saying I'm so
glad you're what are you even talking
about
I haven't had anybody our particular
there's so many voices of comedy yeah
and that's what's great about it but
it's BV it's being over analyzes let us
just go to our joke joke corner like
idiots because that's only hard well
when you get on the road the people are
paying a lot of money to see you make me
laugh [ __ ] and that dude they
should do me yeah I'll try to say
something my last special I'm getting
too old not to say something I'm getting
told not to care enough about I read too
much not to have a point of view right
yeah yeah and I try to let that sort of
I do it generally where I where I will
comment on the destructive elements of
the trending conversation or so I'm
gonna that's gonna seep its way in yeah
but don't don't look to me I'm not your
do not stand there and and and think
that you are I always think like if I
had a special what would I call it and I
think I would call it this changes
nothing because it's just funny it's
just I need to figure I feel the same
way about art stuff I make like I'm just
we're just making things because the
existential crisis of being alive yeah
is a lot yeah and we're very lucky to be
able to do this as or make sure what
changes you're welcome is sitting too
much
I was not playing for 13 yes we're gonna
talk about your trip that much was there
anything cool exciting why just that I
didn't do enough I had the best duck
I've ever had in microphones like your
mic I had little to that that she had
the best I had the best girl Mike I had
the best duck I've never seen him Mike
roll its eyes before that's what gives a
[ __ ] I trip with [ __ ] because I I got to
Beijing and I and I found out we had to
drive two and a half hours so I said
before we go I have to eat and I want
authentic Chinese woman said are you
sure you want Chinese I want I want real
Chinese shoes because we can go to
McDonald's I go listen to me I want
Chinese food so we went to this Chinese
restaurant they had bullfrogs - we had
duck feet yes and mustard wasabi they
had they had turtle soup they had small
turtles or big turtle soup chicken
viscera so you had chicken guts
I see if you can't remember China has a
lot of people to feed and they go we
went to family used all of me you eat
everybody use all me and everything and
then I had but I had pork and like would
you think it's pork it's something
heavily spiced Hunan [ __ ] that's heavily
supposedly you don't know what you don't
know that means your honor she said she
goes you don't know and vegetables and
but I have to say that it's good like
you're you're gonna need some spicy [ __ ]
my skin didn't like it my skin didn't
like it my skin hated it but because I
get psoriasis I saw everything blurting
I know I know it's hot but having said
that and then we drove to junjin which
is a sprawling city of ten million at
least I shoved into a space as big as
Glendale yeah and things things on a
movie set in junjin R or in China in
general are not the smooth running
machine that is Hollywood a lot of
people don't know because they're not
experienced that film industry's about
ten years old so there's a lot of
glitches there is no air conditioning
and it's 95 degrees the inside you're
assuming it was a very intensely
uncomfortable yeah and then when I went
to the old part
kangan well there is no real old part it
was there some architecture built by the
British back in the day but that's all
been turned into shops that look that
are selling the things you see on
Hollywood Boulevard and it was so hot
and I when they dumplings at a street
restaurant a place where you go yeah and
and even the woman I was with who was
Chinese it was from Beijing was like I
can't me now he was tough junjin is not
it is it is a again this is from a
westerner who only saw very little of it
but from what I could tell when you walk
around you're just seeing those now you
spell ti a and Gi n you just see its
giant buildings it's a vertical
experience it's concrete everywhere and
it's uh it's it's just it's it's not the
prettiest place what are you in that
after taxes for that job like would you
bring on no okay yes but it's my
friend's movie good time oh yeah Megan
Fox Josh Duhamel is the great people oh
great love them but but it better better
better Joshua I'm sitting in China
shooting in China is it is an experience
and and it's it's gonna be it's going to
be different and it's going to be it's
gonna be you know it's gonna have its
challenges